votre réaction fermeture dont deux
semaines après la rentrée seulement on
imagine une grande lassitude
de notre côté on avait demandé lors de
l'ouverture de la rentrée qui s'est
déroulé la semaine il ya deux semaines
un couvent du
meta fera cette rentrée malheureusement
n'a pas été écoutés entendus
mardi des n'y en avait demandé de
prévoir la fermeture des établissements
ils vont tellement confinement au vu de
l'augmentation des cas
malheureusement cette annonce et venir
un peu tardivement vendredi
donc depuis aujourd'hui et les
établissements scolaires polynésie sont
fermés et on a une un confinement un peu
andy un confinement partielle de la
polynésie ça paraît invraisemblable
effectivement on a l'impression de
retourner il y a déjà deux ans on
pouvait s'attendre à cette situation
selon vous on aurait pu peut-être
l'éviter
mais pour nous on aurait pu l'éviter en
a à plusieurs reprises appelé le
gouvernement polynésien n'a interpellé
aussi l'état via les eaux commençaient
en polynésie les télés peu été entendu
moi il faut savoir qu'il ya de gros
événements qui se sont passés en
polynésie pour lesquelles nous on se
pose des questions la venue d'emmanuel
marque l'on est et est ce une bonne idée
alors quand on sait à voir les premiers
quarts d'unia tout ça aujourd'hui
l'explosion du quartier qu on est dans
une situation dramatique où aujourd'hui
les sorties de l'hôpital cd sorti
en séries qui permettent à de nouveaux
patients de surtout lors des
interventions d'une hausse et la réalité
du terrain
quid de la vaccination
on voit que le gouvernement martèlent
les écrans de publicité
depuis pour aller encourager un exhorté
les populations à se faire vacciner
qu'en est il chez vous
oui depuis qui depuis la crise on voit
une augmentation du nombre de vaccinés
maintenant il ya des projets de textes
aussi qu'il défend localement avec une
obligation vaccinale maintenant nous on
estime que l'obligation vaccinale elle
peut pas elle va venir on vient aider
dans la gestion de cette crise
l'obligation vaccinale pour le moment
polynésie elle concerne les soignants
est ce qu'il y à un débat éventuellement
sur d'autres populations se serait
souhaitable selon vous puisque seulement
un tiers des habitants semblent vacciner
en polynésie
maintenant l'obligation localement ce
qui a été voté à l'assemblée de
polynésie française c'est une obligation
qui va au delà du personnel soignant
cette obligation elle a été étendue à
tous les fonctionnaires
territoriaux
aux enseignants et à plusieurs autres
corps de métier
troubles emmené dans une situation assez
spécial pour les mises il faut rappeler
qu'il ya eu les essais nucléaires entre
une population qu'à
très peu confiance en l'état donc
maintenant oui il faut faudrait sûrement
que la vaccination accélère mais
maintenant nous on estime que la
priorité devrait demi sur ceux qui ont
déjà des cours mobilité et les
personnages et c'est les personnes les
plus fragiles qui sont vaccinés en
premier
pas forcément
les salariés qui est prêt à brader
défendre peut-être moins grave de la
maladie pas se retrouver en réanimation
aujourd'hui le gros problème qu'on a
c'est qu'il y en a une et les animations
qui au delà de la saturation et moi pas
tu mens à notre sens sera pas retenir
télé longtemps ce rythme est là
aujourd'hui clairement
vous demander quelque chose au
gouvernement
de mettre en place un vrai confinement
qui va au delà des annonces qui ont été
faites
voilà on est pour nous dans un
confinement partiel ou en laisse comme
tout le monde de continuer à vaquer à
ses occupations
on a des doutes sur les chais que sa
produira une autre grosse crainte c'est
que au final au lieu d'être confiné
totalement pendant 15 jours doit ce
qu'on finit pendant peut-être un mois et
demi est ce que c'est la vie de la
population autour de vous ça ne fait pas
peur à nouveau confinement justement
fils du moins il ya une partie de ces on
a dit que la population est partagée
mais beaucoup voulaient avoir un
confinement déjà dès les premiers morts
qui a pu avoir il ya deux semaines
maintenant il sera fait entre santé
économie appelée l'équilibré est
complexe moi je
je lave mais maintenant on sait que
le comité ne se déplacent à tout seul
malheureusement c'est
laisser les personnes qui les
transmettent maintenant l'un des moyens
pour en attendant d'avoir un taux de
vaccination
convenable c'est de
t'arrêter
totalement le pays pendant un certain
temps
merci en tout cas mais à nous soucier
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france pour nous exposer dans cette
situation en polynésie française